the centerpiece of Tibet's capital Lhasa
is the imposing potala palace at 12,000
feet above sea level
it's the highest palace in the world
it's also a major Centre for Buddhist
spirituality potala refers to a sacred
mountain in India and for centuries its
namesake palace has been at the core of
Tibet's monastic community much of the
palace dates to the 17th century but the
earliest construction began a thousand
years earlier on commission of a Tibetan
King in honor of his marriage to a
princess of China the growing fortress
became the winter home for the dalai
lama's monastic leaders of tibetan
buddhism unesco world heritage
designation extends to the neighboring
jo king temple considered Tibet's most
sacred
it also includes Norbulingka once the
dalai lama's summer residence
conflict led to the exile of the Dalai
Lama from Tibet in 1959 and the grounds
became a museum but the potala palace
remains a major Buddhist pilgrimage site
many travel long distances by foot to
pay their respects potala is divided
into two parts the Red Palace which is
for religious practice and the white
palace for administrative use visitors
to potala have to go with a tour group
and obtain a special permit the heritage
site contains a vast collection of
sacred texts and works of art
potala palace has withstood the elements
and political struggle remaining an
embodiment of Tibetan culture
[Music]
[Music]